bonjour aujourd'hui on est au bhv et
qu'on parle des start up qui partent à
las vegas au cs labellisé français et
aujourd'hui on allait christian qui va
nous présenter sa solution allant
christian tu peux nous présenter ton jeu
la feb a écouté la solution de la voilà
en fait ch
interphone vidéo connectés c'est le
premier interphone qui en fait réunit à
la fois des fonctions d'accueil et des
fonctions de protection du domicile
donc en fait ça remplace une fenêtre ou
une personne à l'accord de votre maison
est simplement quand on quand un
visiteur va venir sonner sur ice et le
nom du produit
à ce moment là et bien vous allez avoir
une notification avec une photo toutes
envoyées sur votre smartphone où que
vous soyez dans le
dans le monde à vous joindre wilkinson
des kanaks te mange en soit la photo de
la personne qui sonne chez nous voilà
avec une notification comme une
notification d'appels téléphoniques et
donc en fait il peut y avoir jusqu'à 8
personnes de la famille typiquement
qu'ils peuvent
à voir la notification est celui qui est
le plus concerné si c'est le copain de
ma fille c'est ma fille qui va décrocher
elle va prendre la vidéo ce moment la
vidéo et voix qui est à la porte d'un
pouvoir discuter bien sûr avec avec le
visiteurs et puis elle va pouvoir ouvrir
la porte
elle va pouvoir si c'est une personne
âgée par exemple comme on a intégré les
fonctions d'une alarme
elle va pouvoir déclencher l'alarmé à
syriennes pour qu'elles se sont pas
rassurés par les visiteurs mais aussi
c'est un produit qui est une fonction
très intéressante qui la possibilité de
lire des qr codes
ah oui c'est le seul du marché l'accord
est et donc beaucoup de d'utilisateurs
l'on s'asseye chez leurs parents par
exemple est la personne qui amène les
repas tous les jours de midi et deux
heures elle présentera un qr code devant
le
devant le pagne et la forte de s'ouvrir
il faudrait une connexion avec les
serrures électriques ou une serre
connecté on révise qui a et à ce moment
là ça va ça fonctionnera donc tu peux la
dérouillée distance ah oui le par ton
smartphone voilà tout à fait on a
vraiment là
simplifier la vie des gens on a pensé
effectivement bien sûr comme hôtes et
les personnes âgées les personnes qui
font de la location temporaire cot ça
permet de se classer toutes les clés les
problèmes de créant de l'éclair remettre
les clés équipe voilà et puis aussi gros
gros sujets pour tout le monde le croit
pour la plupart des gens en tout cas la
livraison à domicile qui n'a pas râlé 25
foire au boudin
la livreur qui est dit qu il est passé i
ou encore hier voilà voilà et ben là
vous allez pouvoir le voir vous allez
pouvoir le discuter avec lui et lui
donner les instructions d'ouvrir la
porte
j'arrive dans cinq minutes c'est
vraiment un produit qui est fait pour
les usages de tous les jours le
quotidien c'est simplifier la vie des
gens c'est l'adn
moi j'ai une question sur la sécurité et
où tout passe par le réseau cellulaire
tendu par le wifi comment ça fonctionne
alors c'est aussi une des
caractéristiques
unique du
de ce produit c'est que il se connecte
en wifi comme beaucoup d'objets
connectés mais en fait quand vous êtes
portail un portillon chose comme ça le
wifi est pas toujours suffisant et donc
on a un fait un partenariat avec l'ange
d'accord même assez importante sur la
place et donc la sim est déjà dans le
produit la connectivité la connexion
ces cimes card est déjà dans le produit
est donc soit de la statue installée
fait simple quatre vis une deux fils
pour l'électricité et puis ça va
fonctionner et si ça passe en wifi va
très bien livré avec une signe qui
servira ça arrive
sinon vous nous demandez pour koné vers
nous c'est votre profil avec la
connexion et vous pouvez demander
l'activation de la quantité que jesse
d'un abonnement de six euros par mois et
donc à ce moment là nous on va vous avez
votre sim dans votre produit et vous
auriez rien à faire pas des
installations pas à faire le tour de
tous les pronostics
dès 20h le truc qui prend la tête aussi
assez souvent et donc voilà donc
connexion soit en wifi 104g cette seule
sur le marché 4 et en sécurisation des
données du coût du compass parler
les réseaux est-ce qu'on a des risques
de piratage de ces intercepteurs signale
déjà bien des villes et en gagne quand
on a ce genre de produit on fait très
attention là
la connexion
les eaux
à ces risques là je dirais qu'on a on a
trois trois possibilités la preuve notre
propre aussi vite et 3 passes du design
la première c'est on a utilisé des
technologiques et sur les technologies
bancaires des places pour la vidéo on
est pour les techniciens cdu voie verte
et c'est donc c'est vraiment un tuyau
qui est difficile à
à créer à percer et puis bien entendu on
a prévu parce que qui peut prétendre sur
un interphone qui par exemple six ans
prétendre à un garantie à tous en fête
ont la possibilité nous à distance si un
problème de sécurité d'envoyer des pages
de sécurité à distance sans que le
client n'a rien à faire
donc on a la possibilité de s'adapter
aux menaces dix jours à venir
et ça on sait déjà le père avec la
puis sans avoir à venir est ce que c'est
un produit qui est déjà disponible sur
un marché alors c'est un produit que
déjà en rend compte déjà plusieurs
centaines de produits installés avec des
clients qui sont obèses ont ravi lycée
il est en vente sur notre site
c'est un mec très loin dans la
description le prêt public ses 390 notre
rôle est donc ça peut installer avec un
produit qui rassemble l'ensemble de ses
fonctions d'accueil dont les deux tiers
et de protection puisque effectivement
il ya la détection aussi de mouvements
automatiques à une scierie de regret
donc vraiment vous avez la possibilité
de protéger votre corps vous voyez avec
mais parce que tu as fait présentation
et tu disais que s'il ya un cambrioleur
way qui se présentent à ta porte
ouais la plupart des gens brio leur
passent pas la porte à la détection de
présence à la filmer on aura leur tête
donc même si long
cambriolé au moins on a une base d'un
faux déjà il ya plusieurs éléments en
fait effectivement c'est que ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que 80% des
cambrioleurs qu'est ce qu'ils font avant
d'entrer qui sonne non sur escaut ses
partenaires avant c'était quelqu'un
qu'en général ils ont près de 4 millions
rien parce que si vous êtes derrière la
poste
nous repas que des gens des cagoules
voilà donc et donc s'il sonne vous avez
une photo est donc une notification sur
n'importe où mais ici ce n'est pas comme
si ça doit effectivement on a aussi
détection de mouvements différents ce
qui va permettre effectivement là aussi
s'il reste un peu trop longtemps aient
un terme à la
vous allez recevoir une notification à
ce moment là vous prenez la vidéo vous
pouvez discuter avec lui lui demander ce
qu'il veut
éventuellement même déclenché ray
crochet la sirène qui est intégré
mettons on est allé au delà de ça sur
abonnement mais en fait qu'on a
considéré que là aussi
il pouvait y avoir un doute à dire que
vous voyez quelque chose qui se passe
chez vous papa est rassuré et donc on a
un partenariat avec un autre parent
c'est important qu'ils aient accès
assistance et à ce moment là vous avez
pu voir depuis l'application déclenché
appelé à ces assistances qui va envoyer
m
gardez un veilleur qui va pouvoir faire
le tour de chez vous voir s'il n'y a pas
eu d'effraction ou qui va rester s'il ya
eu la porte est restée jusqu'à après
trois heures et quarante huit heures sur
l'action sur place qui va vous permettre
de rassurer puis vous donner le temps de
voilà donc vous voyez un ensemble on
essaie de soupe lui conseille percevront
leur usage sera conservée sur l' usage
quotidien de
personne c'est vraiment l'adn de finale
génial super bien merci ça doit aussi
beaucoup à bertoua by plaisir je vous
invite à laisser des commentaires du
post que vous en pensez vous est ce que
vous connaissez déjà ce type de produits
oui non parce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà été cambriolé
au final est ce que ça aurait pu vous
serez là j vous mettiez tout ça en
commentaire on discute ensemble je vous
invite à vous abonner amusé des jeunes
pousses
nous on sera très bientôt ciao